once I believe nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word is believed and I
believe in people more than they believe
in themselves and my sincere hope is
that if you see in you what I see in you
you'll go off and change the planet and
this is a new video today when we
haven't done before it's called how
billionaires think success advice from
the top there's some key messages here
that I hope you'll take with you to
start seeing the world in a little
different way and some of that rubs off
onto you help you go off and do amazing
things
enjoy
I advise students as much as possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job I mean you know
don't sleepwalk through life but don't
don't say it's all going to be great you
know I'll do this and I'll do that you
know I'm just marking time to be older
that I've told people that's like saving
up sex for your old age I mean it just
is not a success in it it is not a good
idea yeah what are you urging them to do
I'll explain here's what I'm talking
about this diet it just yeah you really
want to be doing what you love doing and
you can't necessarily find it on your
first job right but don't give up before
you find it
I really thought like how can I provide
advice that would be most helpful and
I'm not sure I'd given enough thought to
two that to give you the best possible
answer but I think I think certainly
being focused on something that you're
confident will have high value to
someone else and just being really
rigorous in making that assessment
because people are tend to natural human
tendencies wishful thinking so a
challenge for entrepreneurs is to say
well what's the difference between
really believing in new ideals and
sticking sticking to them versus
pursuing some unrealistic dream that
doesn't actually have merit and it that
is it that is a really difficult thing
to to tell you can you tell the
difference between those two things
so you need to be sort of very rigorous
in your self self analysis I think
certainly extremely tenacious and and
then just work like hell I mean you just
have to put in you know 80 hour 80 100
hour weeks every week and then that way
that's all those things improve the odds
of success okay
I mean if other people are putting in 40
hour work weeks and you're putting in
100 hour work weeks then even if you're
doing the same thing you know that in
one year you will achieve what they
achieve you will achieve in four months
what it takes them a year to achieve
you just have to try different things
and even even if 99% of them fail you
only have to be right one time you don't
have to figure it all out in advance you
can be wrong you could pick the wrong
career you can pick the wrong job you
can pick the wrong spouse you can pick
the wrong whatever but you get it right
one time you're set but if you don't try
and if you don't go out there and try
all those different things you'll never
get that one time and so it's not a
question of okay how much stuff is
different stuff do I do or how many
different things should you try try them
all try and volunteer you find the one
you like and then it's like it gets
really easy because if it was picked up
you're on a mission you're loving what
you do you know and then then it gets
easy and so that's just the approach
I've always tried to instill in people
who work for me and myself
so it's it's easy to have ideas it's
very hard to turn an idea into a
successful product there are a lot of
steps in between it takes persistence
relentlessness so I always tell people
who are you know who think they want to
be entrepreneurs it's you need a
combination of stubborn relentlessness
and flexibility and you have to know
when to bewitch and basically you need
to be stubborn on your vision because
otherwise it will be too easy to give up
but you need to be very flexible on the
details because as you go along pursuing
your vision you'll find that some of
your preconceptions were wrong and
you're going to need to be able to
change those things so I think taking an
idea successfully all the way to the
market and turning it into a real
product that people care about and it
really improves people's lives it's a
lot of hard work
I actually I spent a bunch of time
analyzing and in reflecting on why it
was that we were even able to do it
because all like all reasons suggest
that we shouldn't have been able to do
it right because all these other
companies had way more engineering power
and and and servers and time and money
and all this stuff and I actually think
that this is a pretty instructive thing
for anything that you want to go do
because this is the same property is
going to be true for any thing that you
guys start is that someone else is going
to have more resources and be able to do
it the reason why I think we actually
ended up being the ones doing it is
because we just cared way more about it
than everyone else right so there were
always projects some of these other
companies that were these hobbies but we
always thought that was this really
important thing and really just like
felt in our gut in our heart that we
wanted to do it and you know early on
there were always these skeptics saying
that all of us can't be a business we
didn't actually care that much about it
being a business early on but a lot of
the reason why bigger companies didn't
invest in it was because it wasn't clear
that there was a model that would work
for it it seemed like a bad idea yeah
and I actually think that that's true
for a lot of the best ideas where is
that it's not that someone else can't do
it they actually can and the odds are
stacked against you but I think often
that belief and the fact that you just
care so much about what you're doing is
the only thing that kind of drives you
to do it and you know to be honest that
kind of drives me to this day I mean one
of the big emphasis points for the
company right now is internet.org and
you know for why we have this rallying
cry of can we connect a billion people
and you know when we started talking
about that we thought that was crazy
right it was way bigger than any service
in the world that had been built and you
know it's ten digits long right it's
like you know it just it felt crazy we'd
never get to that but then the thing is
as we've started to actually get closer
to that we took a step back and like
alright well our mission isn't actually
to get one in seven people in the world
to be connected it's we want to connect
everyone so it's um it's a big issue
that only around a third of the people
in the world have access to the Internet
and that's something that we think that
we can do something about and similar to
early Facebook we don't there's no
business model around this I mean all
the people who have all the money in the
world I mean it's not necessarily
fair thing are already the people who
are on Facebook right it's in the first
you know 7th of the world but we just
believe really strongly it's like this
is what we were here to do this is what
our company cares about I care about it
the team cares about it our culture
cares about it so we're just going to
keep pushing on it and I actually think
a lot of the reason why great stuff gets
built is because it's kind of irrational
at the time but so it kind of selects
where the people who care the most about
it doing it
we are not a company that normally China
Connor will our self accompanies running
a platform a company that is running an
ecosystem we are almost everywhere
people say Jack you know you are in the
b2b b2c and you're calling C to be on a
finance and online payment logistic
cloud computing you are everywhere
not because we're greedy not because we
want to do it because we have to do it
if we cannot if we do not to do it
China ecommerce in the years were
collapse I remember nine years ago when
I started that a leap a people say yet
don't touch the financing sector because
it's illegal you may be in prison and I
we taught ourselves if we don't do it
the Chinese e-commerce were always like
a I got chat room everybody said it's a
good thing and yeah I don't pay you
don't get the things so say well put me
in the prison let's make sure that Ali
pay the payment solution works and
people say the payment solutions such a
stupid idea it's a escrow service I tell
you hold the money and you get the
things you pay the money if you don't
get the things you want return the money
they say it's a stupid product and I say
as long as they solve the problem
I like stupid things you know let's make
stupid things smart keep on improving
every day
everything I did I was following
something I really cared about something
I loved something I was passionate about
and I kept following that passion
whether it was cars whether it was
anthropology whether it was art
photography and eventually it led me to
my huge passion my real passion which
was making movies which combined all of
those things and I realized that had I
gone on to get my degree in anthropology
I would have probably made
anthropological movies in New Guinea or
someplace and eventually been on
National Geographic and you know the
History Channel and been than making
features and I had done Star Wars just
the same if I'd gone into arts center
and become an illustrator I would have
probably started doing animation and
doing animated films and making animated
things and then ultimately having gone
on and been right where I was so no
matter which route I took because I
cared about all of them they all led to
the same place had I done what my father
had wished me to do which is to go into
these office equipment business with him
which I knew labels that were going to
do I knew I hated that my life would
have been unpleasant and so I think it's
very important not to do what your peers
think you should do not do what your
parents think you should do or your
teachers but to do what you inside or
even your culture things but do what's
inside you
so what's your advice to these small
business founders today we're card
you're going to need some luck but the
harder you work the luckier you get
and if it doesn't work out that's not
the end of the world I just don't have
anything in common with people that sit
there and say oh my god it was terrible
so it's over that's water over the dam
under the bridge get on with it and
start another business the next day or
another career and be honest look in a
mirror and say why didn't it work out
well it wasn't the skill set or it
wasn't I didn't have the temperament for
it or I was in the wrong place wrong
time
maybe I can afford to do it again maybe
I can't but people aren't honest with
themselves they what I've always done is
I've taken a yellow pad I draw a line
down the middle write out the pros and
one side the cons on another in the
sense that if I had let you see it you
wouldn't laugh at me and then when I get
done I just rip it up and throw it away
because I've worked out in my mind what
is real and what isn't and what I can
present to people and I can't
I mean what made you single-handedly
decide to replenish America's bison herd
[Music]
save everything remember
I'm supposed to be shooting for
something that's impossible to have
happen in my lifetime and he has done
the impossible many times like the 1979
Fastnet race off the coast of England a
massive storm ripped up winds and waves
that left 15 sailors dead to this day
it's considered the most dangerous ocean
race ever and Ted didn't just survive he
won and that's where we started our
conversation about his amazing life was
there ever a moment that you thought you
wouldn't make it no but I didn't spend
the whole lifetime thinking about not
making it I was trying to figure out how
to keep going were you afraid no did you
ever think of not going through with the
race with it ever stopping out no way
every night dropping out with CNN
my goal is to simplify complexity I just
want to build stuff that really
simplifies our base human interaction
Twitter was around communication and
visualizing what was happening in the
world in real-time Square was allowing
everyone to accept the form of payment
that people have in their pocket today
which is a credit card so we've built
the simplest way to accept credit cards
and it's just this little tiny device
that we give away for free and you just
download some software from the App
Store and you plug it in to your mobile
phone or your iPad and suddenly you can
take credit cards so if you're a tax
accountant or a lawyer or a doctor or
you know even a hairstylist you can now
accept credit cards thank you guys so
much for watching I'd love to know what
did you think did you enjoy this video
did you take something from it what was
your favorite point do you want to see
the series continue or not to the brand
new test for me let me know leave it in
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
[Music]